foreign
Town H-Town and talk to Alex hey what's
up Alex
Dr Delaney how are you I'm partying man
how about you
better than I deserved excellent I'm not
partying at all actually I'm at work
what are you doing man
not much
very cool how can I help
um okay well
um um just in short um I have a history
of being very rageful
um if a person is trying to make me mad
or angry and they say the right thing
I can girlfriend very happy to full-on
rage mode very quickly uh this has
resulted in a wedge between my parents
and myself it resulted in me pushing
away my ex-girlfriend whom I still love
with all my heart and I'm curious as to
how I can get rid of this because it's
turning me into something that I don't
recognize
I mean it sounds like emotional
regulation issues how long have you been
rageful
my mom says it started when I had brain
surgery
lead with that dude lead with that
so I had brain surgery and then I became
uh had some emotional regulations what
kind of brain surgery did you have
I have had a blood
okay so you've got brain lesions so they
go in and take out a chunk of your brain
somewhere what'd they do
it's attempted so it was a week and a
half of brain mapping
and wait for your seizures and then
track them and Trace them
and try to try to determine where
exactly the stages are coming from yep
where were yours coming from
they determined it was it was far too
close to Broca's area that if they cut
into that area
um and missed I would not I would not be
able to speak for the rest of my life
worst case scenario oh so that was down
in your frontal lobe
yeah nothing nothing they said they made
my choice they said we would need
parental consensus I'm saying it's down
there I think that's that area right
behind your ear right oh yes yes sir
okay
um and so it was close it was far enough
back that they didn't want to dig in
there
okay all right
um
okay
you know I'm not I'm not entirely
certain if since I I didn't suffer like
a a massive like massive brain damage or
a head injury I'm not sure if there's a
correlation between change and behavior
and just like an invasive surgery such
as that
um but that's when my my parents said
that
um my my anger started to increase
so I've got two trains of thought here
okay and I want to just say outright I'm
not a neuroscientist by any stretch of
the imagination not even close Okay
um my first thought is have you heard of
the Phineas gauge story
when the the bolt went like through his
eye and out yeah it shot through his
front
yeah he was a railroad guy in the 1800s
and he was packing powder and it
exploded and he shot it like a missile
through his brain and uh but he lived
and the story goes before this happened
he was a fun-loving fun guy and the part
of the brain that it severed that it
shot through
um had to do with emotional regulation
part of his brain in his frontal lobe
and
he the people around him said he became
a radically different person he couldn't
keep down a job and then 12 years later
he ended up with some pretty significant
seizures and he passed away but he
became really they called him the father
of Neuroscience because it started this
idea like oh there's certain parts of
your brain that house certain activities
and certain
um where's memory and where is motor
functioning and where is thought and
where is laughter and where's fear all
that became came from
oh he lived he's just a totally
different guy now and
so that's my first thought either you've
got a brain lesion somewhere or when
they were in there messing around
um
something happened
that's number one
the other side of it is
you may have heard me say this if you
ever listen to the show but anger I
believe
is to quote Rage Against the Machine
anger anger is a gift
it points us towards things that are not
as they should be
or as we see them not as they should be
and I view rage as caged up anger with
nowhere to go and it becomes explosive
and I can imagine if I'm you
now again I'm rattling off top my head
here okay I if I'm you and I've been
suffering from seizures for so long
how were they Grandma seizures
they're called partial conflicts ah
jeezed only a side half of my brain and
do you know when they're coming or they
just hit you out of the blue
and what's the
um do you get catatonic do you do you
have a full-on seizure on the ground
like what what what is your physical
um expression of these seizures
[Applause]
face or someone who is not familiar with
what a seizure looks like
they would think that I'm kind of just
like hitting them out and just you know
not paying attention to what they're
saying I might just stand up and like
walk around aimlessly uh pick something
out put it down
um
I've had one grand mal seizure in my
life okay so when you have these
seizures you feel them coming on they
come so frustrating
it's like you're not in control of your
body right
exactly they haven't released twice a
day okay
and you go to all this brain mapping all
this surgery
they get all this stuff done
and they tell you sorry man we can't
help you
if that's me
I would be angry that I got this brain
I'm looking at all these kids in my
grade and they've all got brains that
are different
that seem to be functioning and they're
drinking them and smoking them away but
I got one that chooses to shower me with
elect electricity a couple of times a
day and I I
and then the doctors say hey we can't do
anything for you
and that just puts a lid on that anger
and in my world that's rage
and so what I'm telling you is I don't
know if this is
um physiological or if it's
psychological
what I think is important is you've
identified this as a problem is that
fair
absolutely yes sir
is it something that you have determined
you are unable to help
uh
um my my anger yes your rage
you're lashing out at people's what I'm
asking you yes yes for example my
parents
girlfriend was one of them
um I regret it immensely
but do you do you if you and I were just
sitting across a table looking at each
other would you tell me she said a thing
and I was physically unable to stop what
happened next
or if you Plumb the depths of Alex would
you say no I was just so mad and
frustrated I just snapped but I could
have not
it's hard because it's a little bit of
both
um
once I have started yelling at someone
that's when I'm unable to stop that's
fine so what what how far up the river
can you move
I so for example
the other the other night my mom said uh
it was it was my fault that
um
my girlfriends and I broke up and she
was right she was just telling me things
that were true that I did not want to
hear and I just kind of had to bite my
tongue and let's stop right there let's
stop right there
what if
when your mom starts telling you
something you don't want to hear
and you feel your body as though you
feel a seizure coming on you start to
feel your body tense up
and it starts to become a powder cake
what if you said Mom I love you
the things you're saying are right
I need to distance myself from this
conversation for a minute
um let's Circle back at another time
and that other time maybe when you've
had more rest the other time maybe when
you're not stressed out the other time
may be before work instead after work
any number of things
okay but when I say how far up River can
you get there's a moment when you're
going over the waterfall it's too late
man that thing's we gotta we gotta that
boat's going over the waterfall and we
got to see what happens at the end of
that cycle right yeah and I don't know
enough about I wouldn't even know what
to do if I looked at your brain scans or
anything like that so I don't know I
don't know what the surgeons did I don't
know any of that of your psychological
State I don't know any of that stuff
but based on what you're telling me I
think the adventure is not trying to
hold back a boat going over the
waterfall
I think the adventure is
knowing uh oh I just found myself on
this highway again and this isn't a good
Highway for me
so I'm gonna go ahead and just stop the
car and I'm gonna get out and walk if I
need to but I'm not gonna go down that
Highway
and what what I'm guessing you're gonna
find is some significant increases in
self-control that you didn't otherwise
have before
does that make am I making sense
yes is that scary frustrating because
here's the deal all of us have to do
that on a daily basis
your your project ahead of you is just
going to be harder than mine
and I think we just have to own that
reality
do it accepting the way things are
currently
um is is very uh hard to do it is
it is what's the alternative
um
[Music]
yeah
I'm kind of done going to war Alex
all I look around to see a pile of
bodies in my life and I'm kind of done
with that
so I'm going to make peace with it
I'm gonna make peace with it
but um I I heard you you talked about
speaking about you know how children
should be brought up your whole like you
know they should they should want to
come home
I want my parents to think that I I want
to come home I don't want them to think
that I hate them
okay
have you here
number one you can't control what your
parents think and I hate that for you
but you can't
the second thing is
is no matter what's happening
behaviorally your parents have some sort
of guilt over the way your brain works
the way parents are
they're wondering what they mean my
brain works Yep they're wondering what
they ate to give you this genetic
issue or what they
how what part of their DNA contributed
to the wiring system you know like
parents will go to the they will find a
way to blame themselves dude
and so it may be
you do what I just said in that last
segment but you're doing it for parents
you flip it around how old are you
23 sir 23.
man
can you imagine scrounging the money up
and taking your parents out to a cheap
breakfast
at Cracker Barrel there in Houston and
saying Hey I want y'all to know I love
you so much I'm so grateful for
everything you've done
and I'm gonna get to the bottom of this
thing and I'm gonna ask you to number
one
um stay with me don't give up on me
because I'm not giving up on y'all and
I'm not giving up on Alex
can you imagine that conversation
that would be amazing
can you do that
yeah would you do that here's it would
you do that for you because you're
carrying so much weight my brother
and here's the other piece of that
letting them know
I I'm gonna work on just use that
analogy I just gave you I'm gonna work
on trying to reclaim my emotional
regulation and that means I'm gonna have
to get way up River
and sometimes I may put my hand up and
say
I need to back off step away from this
conversation
um if you can give me a half hour I
would really appreciate it
and
to tell them don't take this as a sign
of disrespect I'm not being ugly I just
feel my body heading down a river that
has a waterfall at the end of it I don't
want to do that
trying to choose a different way
and over time your body hopefully will
def will settle in and if it doesn't it
may never ma'am
you've got some neurological
architecture challenges that the rest of
us don't have
and so again instead of going to war
with reality just knowing I need to
avoid these kind of confrontations
because I get to a place where I can't
come back
and I would strongly recommend that you
get with the neuropsychologist and see
if there's some sort of
um
some sort of exercises you can do to
begin to practice emotional regulation
the brain's got a magical way of
drawing from other parts of the brain
that don't normally do activities to
engage that part of your brain to pick
up the slack
okay have you already done that have you
met with a neuropsychologist
with a psychologist and I'm
neuropsychologist okay there's some
there's psychologists that are trained
to look at your brain and to say okay
here's the particular challenges in this
particular part of your brain they're
gonna they're gonna they're going to
express themselves behaviorally in this
way and so let's work here
I don't want to give you some tasks that
are just unreasonable because of your
brain architecture right
yeah sure I don't want you to beat
yourself up for things that you can't
help I also don't want you to avoid
things that you could help you just
didn't have a guy to take you through
the jungle
but beyond all this stuff before I let
you go
don't give up on Alex man
thank you I'm serious I can hear you I
can hear you're just freaking tired
I am
so tired
probably tired of the seizures tired of
hurting people that you love tired of
being alone tired of feeling alone I
all my life
all I've ever thought about is myself
I took my family for granted
I heard people that I loved
and I I just I don't want to be that
person anymore okay
two things number one don't be
number two
cut yourself some slack dude you've been
trying to not die your whole life
is that fair
a couple of times a day every day for
your life you are struck by lightning
no matter where you were in the bathroom
with friends talking to a cute girl
wherever you happen to be
you always knew at some point I'm gonna
get hit and I don't know when and I
don't know where and I don't know how
it's going to look to the person I'm
talking to
and that made you short and that made
you frustrated and that made you hard to
be around sometimes big whoopty freaking
do
foreign
yes
if a little 12 year old boy came up to
you and was trying to apologize because
somebody said I'm gonna punch you in the
face twice today you're never gonna know
what's coming
and you walked up and that kid snapped
at you like hey
and they said oh my gosh I'm so sorry
sir I'm so sorry sir you would get down
on both knees and say little boy
someone told you they were gonna hit you
it's okay it's okay and you'd hug that
boy tightly wouldn't you
absolutely yes
hug Alex for me because you're not right
here in front of me
thank you okay
thank you
don't give up
what I imagine for you in the future is
you've got an extraordinary story to
tell
little kids in your exact same situation
that one day you become a really
pathfinding neuroscientist or you become
a great local counselor or you just
become a great accountant
that's got a temper
and that sometimes abruptly walks away
from conversations
but that people look to because you're
honest and you really understand what it
feels like to not be at home in your own
body
and so you're able to sit with people
through all sorts of hell that they've
walked through
what I'm saying is the world needs you
don't don't Rob the world of the gifts
you're gonna give them
get the help you need my man
so grateful for you